partiamo dal presupposto che lo sfondo
alle mie spalle cambia ogni 5 minuti
però ancora aspettando il momento giusto
per fare il videoclip bait il mio nuovo
studio però non lo farò adesso oggi
ragazzi siamo qua perché mi capita di
guardare indietro volevo fatto avevo
fatto già un video reaction sui miei
vecchi video solo che passano anni ogni
volta che faccio una video reaction sui
miei vecchi video sono tante cose che
ogni volta che riguardo mi sale la
nostalgia ti faccio vedere ad esempio
quello che è il video meno visto del mio
canale fa ridere questa cosa se si pensa
che questo video ha fatto 115 mila
visualizzazioni 12345 video dopo siamo a
2milioni 800mila com'e va bene che il
primo video di happy with questo però 3
milioni di questo nessuno perché grazie
cattelan scatto non puoi passare ti
esorcizzo funziona di base quello che vi
voglio dire che questo video per come è
fatto non merita 2.800.000 misura delle
frasi che viene più utilizzata sul web
ma anche per i cantati qualsiasi cosa
che chi segue una persona da tanto dopo
anni di ceam aerei meglio prima
tutte le persone che dicono fa viti
preferivo com'eri prima in realtà è
perché mi seguivano un tempo e al tempo
provavano emozioni particolari quando mi
seguivano ma se tu guardi un mio video
vecchio i miei video vecchi erano così
fra bomba mamma mia mamma mia mamma o
chi ha questo ai fan
se è così e ragga così no mi avete
lasciato indietro audio da schifo
cappelli che non va beh lasciamo perdere
spesso solo tagli non facevano anche
zoom non facevo non mette neanche la
musica di sottopotere niente tu
confronti è un mio video così vecchio
rispetto a uno di adesso lo siate
obiettivi quello vecchio vaccara non
parlo non si sente ma è normale io non
si senta sto video non si sente non c'è
il volume non si sentono gas
addio ha trovato un bagher il mio canale
l'ho trovato in diretta perché non si
sente mastrillo sondato per mia
curiosità vedere qual era il video meno
visualizzato nel mio canale e alla fine
e ho trovato che questo parteciperò a
news su ben diversa tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo blog ci sono un
sacco di cose in questo video che non
vanno assolutamente bene ne trova almeno
cinque i miei capelli l'audio del video
io stavo usando questo lo vedete questo
coso qua che spunta
però fanno delle cuffie il microfono
delle mie cuffie originali che ho ancora
qua ovviamente questo fa veramente
vomitare i cessi il mondo che ho né di
vestire santo iddio per che cosa che era
quella roba lì e quello che cosa ancora
più gravi che sono la color correction
voi non sapete forse usa una color
correction quando tu fai un video a
giusto in atti mini colori per far sì
che siano sintonizzati qua partiamo dal
giallo anni a finirà il verde e poi come
ultima cosa in assoluto è imposta di
cortina sfondo de mi vida il poster
eccolo qui c'è gente che magari sotto mi
dice
eccolo questo è il vero fa vige ti prego
torna il tema che cazzo dici quindi non
torna coi capelli brutti un microfono di
merda che non sapevo fatto tagli in
croce con la felpa brutta e quelle color
correction diffuso rella e va bene col
poster ricordi quanto sei cambiato
un'altra persona mi dice non c'è la
faccio a guardarlo io non ce la faccio a
vedere questo italiano coinvolgente la
differenza tra questo blog è il blog
successivo molto meglio ora ovviamente
oh mio dio delle persone obiettive che
strano vedere quello che è il mio
surgeons inoltre prime serie v concesso
viso perfetto sta però una cosa che
facevo i tempi e che non ero non ero
pigro come adesso tipo nei video a tema
mi vestivo a tema ci facevo anche finta
di essere un dottore facevo anche le
scenette prepartenza cosa cosa avevo in
testa gesù
[Musica]
[Applauso]
una sigla 28 raul dal gr1 rai che ho
cancellato quella sottoscritto sopra fa
vj dottor house valso profani ieri
bellissimo della mia schifo vj
soprattutto c'è
[Musica]
bellissimo cioè io veramente questa è
una cosa bella era una roba freschissima
ma che prevalente se cerchi
nell'immondizia non trovi di meglio però
l'idea c'era capito cioè ci stava questa
cosa di fontana nostalgia pure a mero
meglio prima a [ __ ]
siete pronti
[Musica]
15 mila iscritti oddio tremando mi farà
strano soprattutto quelli che mi seguono
da quando è mosso 23 milioni di iscritti
4 milioni iscritti ai tempi avere 15
mila iscritti che adesso sono ti conosce
solo tua nonna ai tempi e rari era
veramente incredibile cherie uno dei
rifiuti per più conosciuti ai tempi
15.000 iscritti tutto rigorosamente con
il posto di call of duty modern warfare
3 sullo sfondo ai 30.000 qual era così
al chabib anni o mio dio c'è questa
challenge che consiste nel mettersi dei
marshmallow in bocca e dire chabib anni
genoa cosa stupidissima però con il
tempo queste cose le ho sempre fatte ma
lo fate in tv social feist altro con
cattelan che ho nominato all'inizio di
questo video e offerta è solo perché
grazie cattelan
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e stato bellissimo cattelan
grazie per avermi invitato e per ti
spaccano la mascella e iniziato il
periodo quindi mi amate i pacchi così io
dovevo scartarli nei video perché sono
mi riempivano casa ed era una roba posto
potuto rifare dopo che dopo che che mi
cosmi non sto parlando nel quale sono
passati quanti anni 3 manco adesso zio
anti preoccupà come ultima quale avevo
già fatto nell'altro video reaction
questo ma devo farlo presente perché
merita la vita la gestiamo su barbie
[Musica]
agi
ma gol
cosa sto facendo della mia vita scusate
non è cambiato niente è sempre un
piacere rivedere quello che faceva una
volta spero che anche voi siate
obiettivi dal punto di vista della
qualità di video santo gesù però io
cerco sempre cercherò sempre di portarvi
sul canale ciò che volete ciò che vi
piace perché alla fine è questo il mio
scopo da da quando ho aperto il canale
quindi io sono sempre qui io vi
ringrazio per essere sempre stati con me
in tutto questo periodo ringrazio chi è
con me da una vita e chi è arrivato
anche l'altro ieri in conclusione per la
gioia dei nostalgici riporterò alcuni
giochi di un tempo per quei giochi che
mi sono piaciuti di un tempo anche se mi
rifarò sono comunque passati cinque anni
da quando gli ho fatti quindi manco io
me li ricordo e volte cose le voglio
riportare proprio per nostalgia non vedo
veramente l'ora di farlo credetemi
quindi per i più nostalgici preparatevi
perché avrete degli orgasmi
spero che viene oggi vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi ringrazio tutti l'incasso
cattelan per essere apparso due volte
nel video in due punti diversi
come se i ragazzi se vi sia piaciuto e
mi piace anche alice a comiziare sono
stati restituiti iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo un prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]